everyone you know what we must put you
know what can you run into get my laptop
real quick I'm gonna put on my facebook
as well all right let me talk to people
what's up from Paris I don't hear any
sound really let me see this more sound
yeah Adam what's up it is cool morning
hey you saw that it's cool right it is
cool like people think people else
innovators like watching it yeah it's
gonna go like everybody like they don't
they don't even realize that they're on
I love it
hey everybody say happy birthday to ATLA
hooligan spell that la wh ool IGN yeah
is it gone thumbs up if anybody
remembers quick oh this is weird
filming myself watching ourself I'm
getting let's give it a step on until I
go to do the official yep
so actually look you can actually
everyone good to see you
just fix my hair I'm gonna hand it over
to Stefan
who's going to move on so you guys know
who's handling Stefan so cool very good
so I'll be taping the show and you'll be
able to watch it this way
I'll live everything actually know
what's up I want you to do a little walk
around the office right now this way
they'll miss this question so that would
make them have to watch it later
and then they could also see a bunch of
a nurse stuff yeah
you know we gotta get you in did you see
I I want those same things and so I
think that content itself is the jab
right cool
cat see you later oh you know your your
your yet I still don't know what the
hell that is